So tell us about Cay.
About Cay Skin
About Cay Skin.
which by the way, I was so lucky I got a send out
and I opened it up and stand poured outta it.
Because a lot of the ingredients
and like the whole vibe of Cay Skin,
although I wanted to be every day.
So I didn't want it to be too beachy,
like the rest of sun care that you could find.
I want people to use SPF every day, right.
So I want to formulate Cay Skin to be like skincare
and not just sun care.
So it's very hydrating.
It has things like hyaluronic acids.
Which is so good for you, the hyaluronic acid.
Just draw moisture into the skin.
But then I also wanted to make sure
that there was things that were near and dear to me
like my parents used to cut aloe vera
straight from the plant
in the backyards in Jamaica and rub it onto my skin
for sunburns and for rashes and for mosquito bites
and also sea moss, which has been very trendy as of lately
but in the Caribbean we've been consuming it
and using it on our skin for so long,
so little nods to the Caribbean
and my heritage were really important for me
to put into the first product that I was ever making
and making some scratch.
I mean, I'm not kidding,
I'm so excited for this line.
I think I'm the most excited about this
more than anything else I've ever accomplished in life.
So this is like a dream come true to me.
It's something I'm so passionate about, as well.
I mean, sold.
And what you're bringing in terms of ingredients
it's such a powerful story.
I have to show you honestly a Cay Skin
is so bomb on the skin it like adds a glow.
I have it on right now, but you can see it just.
Yes. Yes, oh my God.
I'm sorry but look at the difference.
Right?
One is like a dead lizard
and the other is like a disco Dolly.
It's true.
Literally like just adds life and hydration to your skin.
That glow ,I'm saying I've been working on this
for three years now.
So it better be given that glow to the glow.
And you are and have access to everything out there.
Well, it's difficult though.
You know, being an entrepreneur is hard for anyone.
So like doing the hard work behind the scenes
and finding those investors even,
and you know this was one fact that I found recently,
I'm one of about a hundred black women
who have raised over a million dollars in venture capital.
So it's kind of hard.
(audience claps)
Insane.
That number to me is so crazy that number's insane to me
that black women aren't being trusted
with their ideas to put things out into the world.
And I wanna make sure that whenever I'm talking
about Cay Skin, I always like to bring that up
so that people are inspired to know that one,
they can do it.
And two, inspired to know that you can trust black women
and women of color, POC, to execute.
Absolutely, and let this be the roaring success
that you have worked for it to be,
and then it will help build other people up.
Now, before we go, if it's okay,
would you do a quick round of before the break, with us?
I'm down.
All right, it's before the break!
Now Winnie, will you give us your top three
best skincare tips in 30 seconds?
Okay. In 30 seconds.
And go.
Number one, I would say, get rest.
You need to sleep.
Your body needs to recharge and it needs to replenish.
That's one.
Make sure you're getting your rest.
Number two, I would say wash your face
before you go to bed.
Don't sleep with that makeup.
I do it sometimes too.
Shh, don't tell nobody.
And number three, of course,
protect your skin and always wear SPF.
Never forget SPF.
Rest, wash your face, SPF.
Winnie, you did that in like 22 seconds.
Yes!
You are intelligent dynamic goddess on the planet.
I would be so honored to do more with you,
are you kidding me.
Winnie Harlow, everybody, sun protection
is so incredibly important, which is why we are so thankful
that Winnie is giving everyone in our audience
a $50 gift card to her sun care line Cay Skincare.
(audience cheers)
Thank you, Winnie.
And very important Cay Skincare
is available Sephora and cayskin.com.
Congratulations on that.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)